Im netz häufen sich die
weltuntergangsszenarien zum 23 april der planet nibiru soll auf der erde einschlagen diese theorie stützt sich auf eine besondere
sternenkonstellation an diesem tag was ist dran was hat es mit dem planeten libero auf sich und was auf jeden fall am
23 april 2018 passieren wird er vater jetzt in clixoom science fiction herzlich willkommen
Es war ein schlimmer tag der 23 september 2017 die welt ging mal wieder
Nicht unter es ist einfach zum mäuse melken immer wenn ein weltuntergang voraus gesagt wird fällt er aus es ist einfach deprimierend
Eigentlich gibt es kaum ein jahr in dem nicht ein bestimmtes datum von gewissen leuten mit spannung erwartet wird weil verschiedene
Katastrophenszenarien vorausgesagt werden im jahr 2017 war es der 23 september
pustekuchen aber und jetzt ist es der
23 april also bleibt uns mal wieder nicht mehr wirklich viel zeit unser leben so wie wir es bisher kennen zu genießt
man eine besondere
Sternenkonstellation soll heute den weltuntergang ja was soll ich sagen
Auslösen verursachen ja ich fasse sich nicht nur weil irgendwelche sterne aus unserer perspektive
Also der der erde irgendwo am himmel
Stehen soll geht die welt unter nur zum nachdenken vom mars oder anderen sternensystemen in unserer
Nähe aussieht der himmel ganz
Anders aus da stehen die sterne woanders oder es gibt die sternbilder gar nicht weil sie eben aus einem anderen blickwinkel
Auf den himmel gucken es ist wirklich, so eine hanebüchener blöd sind ja und diese außergewöhnliche
Sternenkonstellationen die nur alle 100 jahre passieren soll ja allerdings. Im september letzten jahres da war sie so ähnlich
Am himmel zu sehen also
Die sonne, im sternzeichen der jungfrau soll da stehen genauso wie der planet jupiter
Insgesamt befinden sich am 23 april in dem cern sternzeichen zwölf sterne was eben nur einmal alle 100 jahre
passieren soll ja und warum das auch immer noch mal die apokalypse auslösen soll
Also was wird passieren da muss man die den das muss man
den verschwörungstheoretikern lassen sie geben einfach nicht klein bei und erwarten zum meer wirklich xten mal dass ein unbekannter planeten namens nibiru
oder planet iks wie sie in oft auch nennen die erde zerstören wird dieses mal natürlich kann sicher am
23 april 2018 diese theorie beschreibt beispielsweise der britische
autoren
verschwörungstheoretiker david ausführliche hat auch diese schlimme
sternenkonstellation für heute verkündet mit den genannten
auswirkungen also nie büro soll demnach ganz dicht vorbei fliegen oder einschlagen und wohl den großteil aller menschen vernichten
einige der verschwörungstheoretiker gehen davon aus
Dass die öffentlichkeit über dieses ereignis bewusst im unklaren gelassen wird damit sich nur die elite darauf vorbereiten kann wie ihr wisst sind
ähnliche vorhersagen weder für 2003 noch für 2012 noch für 2015 oder
2016 oder 2017
eingetreten ja inhaltlich stützen sich die anhänger dieser theorie
ihrer überzeugung nach auch die nasa die den mysteriösen planet negierung vor längerer zeit einmal mit dem ihrer satelliten
beobachtet haben soll
Weltuntergangs fanatiker sind nämlich davon überzeugt dass die nasa nibiru und es hat
83 entdeckt hat aber seit dem tod schweigt um eine massenpanik auf der erde zu vermeiden jeder
Wissenschaftliche beitrag indem irgendwie der begriff plane ticks vorkommen wird von ihnen als bestätigung für ihre katastrophen
Szenarios angesehen was wirklich dahintersteckt den begriff planet extreme gibt es ja im
Wissenschaftsstandort tatsächlich er steht aber für einen noch
Hypothetischen planeten es gibt ja immer mehr beweise in den äußeren regionen des sonnensystemen und na klar
auch die nasa sucht nach noch unbekannten planeten
Im äußeren sonnensystem doch mit dem wälzer störrischen nibiru dessen existenz
Nicht nur nicht bewiesen ist also es gibt den anfang gar nicht
Die nasa würde mir. Jetzt wohl recht geben wenn ich
Absolut entwarnung gebe es wird nichts passieren ihr könnt euch
entspannt zurücklegen den ganzen tag und noch alle anderen tage danach genießen aller wahrscheinlichkeit nach
Hätten astronomen solch einen planeten der auf dem weg in richtung erde wäre schon seit einiger zeit auf dem schirm
Eventuell wäre mittlerweile sogar mit dem bloßen auge
Erkennbar und zum schluss kann ich euch noch. Verraten was ganz sicher heute passieren wird ja nichts jedenfalls nichts
besonderes ja wenn ihr
Kein thema verpassen wollen vor allen dingen den nächsten weltuntergang dann sollte der meine nummer
prozenten das könnte hier dann erfahrt ihr auch form von mir vor jedem video
Also bevor das online geht kriegt, er den link könnte es vorher anschauen
garantiert und zum begrüßung habe ich bei ob auch eine
ein kleines goodie für euch und ja auf jeden fall aber auch natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit meinem video das klingt relativ
Ähnlich zum letzten weltuntergang ja das können wir immer noch, zehn jahre weil die erde eben nicht untergegangen ist bis dann
bleibt dran